et
[Musique]
il
je vous demande de vous observez quand
vous étiez dix ans un enfant un petit
garçon une petite fille comme j'avais 10
ans aviez-vous des rêves
est ce que vous avez pensé à échelonner
des responsabilités afin de
responsabiliser
moi je m'envoie cette petite fille de
dix ans je vois évoluer très énergique
mais très ambitieuse quelques pas et que
peut-être turbulente parce que j'aime
beaucoup m à côté de mon père écouter
ses histoires et mon père parlait
beaucoup de la justice sociale avait
occupé des responsabilités dans son pays
il ya eu des xixe et il ya saumon
justice sociale je me vois dans mon
parcours
parce qu'il s'agit de partager ce
parcours un moment où quand l'escaladé
échelon à l'école et puis je commence à
travailler à l'international et j a
indiqué qui m'a fasciné c'est le livre
de john maxwell qui parle de file des
verts au leadership bien cinq niveaux de
leadership
elle parle de quoi pas de premier niveau
qui est la position
vous êtes nommé vous êtes élu comme vous
êtes nommé tout le monde attend de vous
on ne vous connaît pas et vous devez
prouver que vous êtes en leader vous
êtes un manager et que vous allez
évoluer vos équipes pour le voit des
résultats
vous êtes élu tout le monde vous connaît
ils vous ont souvent choisi il vous
connaissent il ya beaucoup d'attentes et
tu dois des livres et vous fait plaisir
à ceux qui t'ont élus dans cette
position tu évolues et tu as livre un
niveau où les gens allaient stimulant
les places que tu leur as donné puisse
donner le meilleur d'eux mêmes il ya
aussi à niveau situé chefs d'entreprise
ils vont avoir des dividendes est ce que
ces dividendes seront versés dans la
société ou
soro il ya une part que tu vas de nous
comme bonus à des employés et même en
bonus que tu vas donner pour aider les
parents progrès des enfants à l'école
etc
tu commences à gagner certaine confiance
mais aussi une certaine stabilité au
niveau de l'équipe et l'autre niveau
c'est que tu puisses 10 mai sont venus
ceux ci que je prends ses dividendes
je leur donnais ce que mes équipes en
personnel super forme
parce que je veux qu'on dénommait de
nous mêmes on a non seulement des
résultats non seulement on a des
dividendes mais ces dividendes commence
à dire je pense aux autres donc tu ton
intelligence émotionnelle où tu dis que
réellement les autres comptes
alors qu'est ce qui a comme résultat
c'est que depp le personnel va suivre
non seulement ils sont contents de venir
et travailler mais se sentent partie de
cette société se sentent partie de cette
grande famille est à l'imitation est
faite comme didn't exist in france mais
plus loin c'est que ta réputation va te
dépasser on peut l'appliquer au niveau
de l'entreprise
on peut appliquer au niveau de la dette
d'un pays on peut l'appliquer partout on
connaît les grands hommes et
biographique nous disons agissait de
l'appliquer dans un cas je suis allé
dans un pays dans mon parcours
il ya beaucoup d'expérience que j'aurais
aimé partager mais je m'arrête à ce cas
là c'est un cas qui était un pays qui
était en difficulté mais un pays qui
évolue est un pays très pauvre où j'ai
eu à travailler et ce pays
particulièrement avaient toutes les
richesses tout la croissance ne
parvenait pas à voir cette richesse
inclusive et tout d'un coup il y avait
un mouvement des syndicats qui était
très fort et qui se soit déporté qui
sont d'aller dans la rue et en allant
dans la rue
les forces ont riposté on a perdu ce
jour-là 100 personnes et parmi les cinq
personnes y avait des enfants qui avait
des bals perdus et qu'ils étaient à
l'hôpital
mon sursaut c'était de dire absolument
parce que
chef des nations unies il fallait trois
niveaux d'où le problème au niveau
politique au niveau social au niveau
humanitaire
je crois que c'était de sauver la vie
des gens sauver la vie des gens c'est
est de sauver ces enfants qui étaient
d'abord qu'on avait évacué et
deuxièmement comment mener des batailles
trois batailles même temps il fallait
aussi ne pas penser que tu peux tout
faire il fallait faire appel aux autres
mais le grand danger c'était que c'est
toi qu'on le garde c'est toi qu'on
appelle même si on faisait appel aux
autres ce terrain donc on a fait tout ça
on va sauver l'humanité déjà vu convoqué
mme petit un petit avion qu'il avait
affrété humanitaire on n'a pas connu
tous les pays on essaie de donner les
médicaments et de sauver la vie déjà et
d'évacuer les gens
le deuxième niveau c'était de dire
comment je vais faire pour que le
personnel qui est dans mon bureau qui
comptait beaucoup de personnel on doit
les évacuer on avait un système dans le
jargon onusien
on part deux faces de sécurité la phase
une deux trois et cadres quand s'élever
à 4 c'est que on n'en peut plus vous
sauver la vie des gens et des personnels
fallait évacuer ce que j'ai fait nettali
vers l'aéroport et on nous disait à ce
moment là c'était une certaine époque
que tu devais que le personnel devait
partir toi même et à ce moment là je
pense que c'est l'époque je dirais non
satisfaits des nations unies où nous
devions partie des scellés gens on en a
besoin de nous et c'est déjà arrivé dans
un pays où aux personnalités massacrés
donc il fallait choisir entre et de deux
faut-il que je parte avec les autres
fautes que je reste dans mon
subconscient de deals du reste on a
évacué
on est allé dans l'avion et tout le
personnel est parti et je crois que le
sentiment quand je suis sorti je dis je
vous laisse pas tmp se dit mais madame
comment vous pouvez rester ça peut pas
tout il ya des balles partout je dis je
dois rester et quand je suis sorti je
voyais les petits enfants qui
m'attendent à l'aéroport qui m'a dit
madame parce que vous aussi vous partez
je dis non je reste avec vous on va
gérer cette crise ensemble alors la
dernière puisque en jeu
arrivé au bureau et que j'ai trouvé tout
un tas de monde parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de militants autour de notre
compagnie et donc il fallait sauver
cette question de sécurité a parfois je
reviens à ça et je n'ai plus tard c'est
tellement parce que c'est capital
comment haut niveau tu dois gérer multi
les crise multidimensionnelle
comment il faut se comporter et surtout
rassurer des autres groupes eux qui
étaient restés mais ma grande surprise
des coeurs à la crise était devenu
tellement forte que tous les gens qui
étaient en train de marcher qui était
resté comme les leaders syndicalistes
sont venus demander l'asile à notre
bureau des nations unies
vous avez sur la convention de vienne on
doit ouvrir son bureau et je des 0 puis
accueilli chez moi dans le bureau et on
avait en fait les élus ce qu'on appelait
le contenu de ce plan tout ce qu'il faut
pendant une semaine qui pouvait nourrir
tout le monde les matelas tout ça et
tout le monde est resté là bas mais je
savais que j'étais suivie par la
sécurité nationale et qu'il savait
exactement ce que je tente de faire avec
ces gens à l'eau tout d'un coup il ya
des métiers qui sont venus de vendre le
bureau et je suis sorti et j'ai rigolé
je les ai deux je me suis mise devant à
jeudi vous savez nous sommes
nations-unies la convention de vienne
est inviolable n'entre pas et personne
ne peut entrer dans son lieu je suis
rentré et ils sont restés après des mois
j'ai appelé les chefs d'état mais parce
qu'on était dans un état de siège et
donc il fallait absolument qu'on puisse
agir très rapidement et sans réfléchir
et j'applique chef de sécurité qui
disait j'ai rejoint ici c'est nos gens
et vous savez le syndicat uni des bulls
entendu bt c'est très syndicalisés et
c'est aussi là pour la justice sociale
il faut protéger il ya les conventions
génève m'appeler rue béteille faut
garder nos gens il faut sauver les gens
et donc ce que je dis à part le seul à
occuper le stratos et que si on a géré
ça c'était vendredi et lundi il avait
déclaré que s'il n'arrête pas le pire va
arriver dans ce pays on avait connu des
exactions dari
donc tout le monde attendait qu'est ce
qui va arriver lundi donc son parti et
moi je suis partie à la maison et je me
disais de g vendredi que lundi vendredi
l'un des pauvres savoir qu'est ce que je
dois faire se lever dans le leadership
je demande escalade dans des cas comme
ça quelle que soit la situation même ce
soit les nations unies tués soeur parce
que tu es responsable et hu devaient
réfléchir ce qu'il fallait faire ce que
j'ai fait c'est que très rapidement j'ai
pensé ce pays est géré son pays à des
autorités et une personne qui gère ce
pays même si serré de bagdad
il faut absolument que c'était
impossible avec l'état de siège qui
était pour retrouver cette personne mais
il a fallu je me faisant des pharmacies
faisant j'ai pu beaucoup de discrétion
rencontrer la personne en question
problème on à poser sérieusement et là
je ne me trouvais plus comment balangué
que vous voyez j'étais devenu autres et
c'est là que je dis que je ne vois là
c'est que quand je lui parlais des
galeries en disant ces gens c'est vos
gens cette population c'est votre
opération
il faut absolument qu'on fasse quelque
chose pour y écouter ce qu'ils ont tenté
de dire ils sont chez moi une aubade que
votre monde est-il heureusement c'est là
où je dis dans les résolutions des
conflits dans les problèmes que nous
avons il ya toujours le moyen de
dialoguer de pouvoir trouver une
solution et à ce moment là que
effectivement à la sortie on s'est
entendus et le soir on annonçait que
l'état de siège est levé la population
va reprendre et négation repris j'ai
fait appel le africaine à la les
autorités régionales qui sont venus
m'aider et des autres de tous les types
qui sont venus nous aider à gérer la
crise et ce serait rétabli qu'est-ce que
j'ai tiré comme leçon je n'ai pu donner
une leçon dans un pays normal mais en
donnant sa 6e
c'est presque du mal à gestion de ce que
nous voyons dans cette tenue
en prison il peut y avoir des situations
tu dois prendre des risques
tu vas pas quatre mois je vais faire
comment j'ai fait cette fois c'est toi
avec toute information tous quitte à
façonner tout ce qui est tu as eu des
hauts et des bas cet endroit au noir en
toi le courage la détermination mais
aussi aux est ce que tu gagnes son
courage d'affronter et d'aller de
l'avant
au niveau personnel je pense que je vais
tirer aussi une bonne leçon c'est que
j'ai appris que depuis le jeune âge même
à l'époque j'aimais beaucoup les lieux
graphie ou d un soutien officiel
j'ai toujours un petit carnet vous savez
ne négligez pas ce petit carnet parce
que c'est là où vous écrivez le ford ou
même de vous même comment vous êtes
sorti de cette situation et attend ça on
continue d'apprendre à continuer leurs
idées chi escalader l'échelle
c'est aussi en longueur c'est continue
d'apprendre et je crois que dans des
situations comme ça nous sommes en
afrique nous parle graphique
nous avons des situations nous avons
aussi dès le bas âge
harry des chiites qui se développe à
nous à l'aider chip au niveau des jeunes
qui ont envie de pouvoir changer les
choses
c'est l'occasion de parler justement de
tête c'est l'occasion de pouvoir dire
nous pouvons yes we can et ses salles
escalader l'échelle des valeurs
c'est ça escalade et évaluera en nous
mais aussi c'est ça escalader des vols
de shit qui change et qui changea les
aimants autour de nous et ensemble nous
pouvons vous remercie
[Applaudissements]